In September 1996, in the
town of Woodsboro, California,
two high school students went on a crime
spree that resulted in the loss of five lives,
while dressed up in these “Father Death” Halloween
costumes. One of the assailants, Billy Loomis,
was motivated to get revenge on his classmate,
Sidney Prescott, because Sidney’s mother had
participated in an affair with Billy’s father,
resulting in his mother abandoning the family.
Sidney eventually defeated Billy
and his accomplice, Stu Macher,
with the help of on-the-scene reporter Gale
Weathers. Gale went on to write a bestselling
novel about the incident called The Woodsboro
Murders. The book was a follow up to her 1995
book Wrongfully Accused:
The Maureen Prescott Murder.
According to Gale Weathers.com, The Woodsboro
Murders came out in late 1996. “Gale Weathers'
second novel details the murderous plot of two
angry teenagers determined to murder Sidney
Prescott and her innocent friends. In a bizarre
turn of events, the author herself became not only
a target of the killers, but a hero. Ms. Weathers'
book became the Sunrise Studios hit movie: Stab.”
Stab would go on to become one of the all time
great long running horror movie franchises. To
learn about the often unknown details of Stab
movies, including the lost trailer for Stab 2,
the differences only included in the theatrical cut of the original Stab, and the dirty movie
studio secrets detailed on this anonymous
website, stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History. The rights to produce
the movie adaptation of The Woodsboro Murders
were granted to Sunrise Studios, who came to
the famed horror movie producer John Milton,
the man responsible for movies like Frankenpimp,
Is Somebody There? and The 1st House on the Right.
He also produced Amazombies, Space Psycho
and Creature From The San Andreas Fault,
all movies that featured actress Rena Reynolds,
which coincidentally, was a stage name for Maureen
Roberts. She ended up getting knocked up at one
of John Milton’s parties; it is unlikely that this
conception was consensual though. After giving
birth to a son, named Roman, she abandoned him and
left Hollywood to reside in Woodsboro, where she
was killed by Billy Loomis to set the real-life
events that Stab was based on into motion.
Milton recognized that Maureen, who had married
and become Maureen Prescott, was Rena, from his
movies, but decided to keep that fact to himself.
– I couldn’t tell anyone.
Can you imagine the press?
– But even before that, Sunrise Studios had another
Woodsboro connection, so to learn about that,
let’s take it back to 1972, when Billy
Loomis’s father lived in Los Angeles.
(mysterious music)
In the early 70s, Henry Loomis was a
lawyer who worked for Sunrise Studios,
and his services were required thanks to a pair
of incidents that occured. The first was on the
production of the cheerleader slasher movie, Is
Somebody There? Actress Elaine Varsi went missing,
prompting Mr. Loomis to send a memo out to
the company, telling them not to make any
comment on the case. Just months later, on June
13th, 1972, during the production of a Russian
terrorist thriller called Shutout! an actress
named Loretta Fisher reportedly disappeared from
the movie’s set in the middle of shooting one of
her scenes, which left everyone baffled.
Ms. Fisher’s family eventually
came after Sunrise Studios for
damages. This lawsuit went on for
over 2 years, but on April 22nd,
1974, either Mr. Loomis was able to find a legal
loophole of some kind that voided the lawsuit,
or Ms. Fisher’s family just had no
money to pursue further litigation.
According to the anonymous expose website
Sunrise Sucks, “the Sunrise lawyer Henry
Loomis parted ways with the Studio the very next
day after the case was closed. Rumor has it he
left Hollywood for good and set up his own private
practice in a small Midwestern town: Woodsboro.”
Of course, we now know that one part
isn’t accurate, because Woodsboro is
located in Northern California, not
the Midwest. Some time after this,
Henry would meet and marry a woman
named Debbie, and together they gave
birth to a son named Billy in the late 70s,
before his affair with Maureen Prescott.
I include this story, because the fact
that Henry and Maureen both worked at,
had a controversy at, and left Sunrise Studios
before having their affair in Woodsboro,
which was instrumental in knocking over
the dominoes that led to the creation
of the Stab franchise, all seems like
it’s too convenient to be coincidental.
But that being said, I can’t picture any
scenario where it isn’t coincidental.
It’s not like John Milton told them to go to
have an affair in Woodsboro so that he could
one day make a movie about it. And Maureen’s son
Roman was only a baby when she left Hollywood,
so he couldn’t have played a hand in it either.
So I think the takeaway here is that Hollywood
corrupted both Maureen and Henry. There were
shady things going on all the time at Sunrise,
and the bad behavior rubbed off on the
two of them. They became shady themselves,
which led to them having an affair. Sunrise
Studios was not the mastermind behind Stab’s
true story, but they still did
kind of cause it, indirectly.
As I mentioned, Billy and Stu slashed up their
high school and Gale wrote a book about it,
which became Stab. Robert Rodriguez, fresh
off the heels of From Dusk Till Dawn, was
brought on to direct. Will Kennison
adapted Gale’s book into the screenplay,
and Dante Paltrow composed the score.
Cinematography was done by Hawken Jones,
who had worked with Milton on Frankenpimp,
and the movie was filmed in Stab-O-Vision!
I don’t know what that is, but I assume it’s
some kind of blacklight effect that shows certain
secrets when viewed through a special lens,
such as a specially outfitted Ghostface mask.
Tori Spelling, who had played Donna
Martin in Beverly Hills 90210,
was cast to play Sidney Prescott. David Schwimmer,
of F•R•I•E•N•D•S fame was cast as the
inexperienced Deputy Dewey Riley. They
got Luke Wilson to play Billy Loomis and Heather
Graham played the human knife-block Casey Becker.
Quick note here from me. After this, the
cast listed on the Sunrise Studios website
that promoted Scream 3 does not line up with
the cast listed in the search results shown
in Scream (2022). I’m considering Scream (2022) to
be canon, so I’ll be using the names listed there.
Does this mean that nothing from
the promotional websites is canon?
Yes, probably. But I still included the stuff
that doesn’t directly contradict the movies,
because it makes this video way
more fun. Back to the cast list.
Jennifer Jolie played Gale Weathers. Christopher
Speed (also known as Joe Blo Nobody) played movie
buff Randy Meeks, and Alicia Silverstone
played Sidney’s best friend, Tatum Riley.
A young Vince Vaughn was cast in his first major
role to play Stu Macher. Ron Howard made a cameo
as Principal Himbry. Craig Bierko, coming
off his success in The Long Kiss Goodnight,
played the role of Cotton Weary, the
man being framed for Maureen’s murder.
The film opens with Casey Becker receiving a
mysterious call before getting in the shower.
Her masked stalker chases her through
the house, and out to the pool area,
where she’s tackled and gutted by Ghostface.
Sidney Prescott and her friends hear
about the murders at school the next day,
and in the evening, Sidney has her own
encounter with Ghostface, which she believes
to be her boyfriend, Billy Loomis. However, she
receives another creepy phone call after this,
while Billy is in custody, so Billy is let go.
He runs into Sidney at school the next day.
– They let me go Sid, I
didn’t do it.
He’s lying. He tries to convince Sidney to get
over her Mom’s death so they can be intimate
again, which doesn’t go well. Sidney manages to
escape Ghostface once more in the school bathroom,
and this time classes are canceled. Shortly
after, so is the school principal’s life.
Tatum’s boyfriend Stu Macher hosts a party that
evening, where Randy explains that horror movies
tend to abide by a set of rules, which the
killers in Woodsboro seem to be following.
– [Randy (Stab)] Never ever ever, under any circumstances, say,
‘I’ll be right back. Cause you won’t be back.’
This results in the deaths of Tatum, the news
station cameraman Kenny, and almost Randy himself,
but in the end, Sidney and Gale are able to defeat
Billy and Stu before any more lives are lost.
The studio would go all out to
promote the release of Stab,
but at the premiere, things
would get a little bit messy.
(blood curdling scream)
(impact)
As I have mentioned, Stab is based on the
in-universe books by Gale Weathers. If I
lived in the Scream universe, I'd want to be
caught up on the books in order to get the most
out of the movie. That's where Audible's
free trial comes in! You can't read Gale
Weathers's books... but you can have the books
responsible for new movies or sequels this year
read to you... like Firestarter, Salem's Lot,
and Jurassic Park. Jurassic. Boys. Jurassic Boys.
But why use Audible when you can just go to
a bookstore, spend a bunch on money and then
read some of it that day, but then just
have it sit on a shelf and not finish it?
Yes, this is directed at you.
The Audible app makes it easy
to listen anytime, anywhere;
across all devices while traveling, working
out, walking, doing chores–you decide.
Audible Premium Plus gives you a free title every
month, or two if you already have Amazon Prime,
and those titles are yours to keep.
But there's also the plus catalogue,
which gives you access to thousands of titles that
you can just listen to without spending a credit.
Protip: use that to sample some books
and then choose what you want to keep.
Audible is giving CZsWorld viewers 30-days for
free, cancel anytime. Just go to audible.com/czsworld
or text czsworld to 500-500. Link
in description: audible.com/czsworld.
(rock music)
The date was April 12th, 1997. The venue:
the Rialto Theatre in Cincinnati, Ohio.
This is where the 10PM sneak preview
screening of the new movie Stab would
take place. Sunrise Studios distributed free
tickets and even handed out Ghostface costumes
to each of the attendees. The atmosphere was
absolutely ****ing electric. Movie patrons
chased each other around the auditorium as cloaked
Ghostface decor flew above the excited audience.
Unfortunately for the moviegoers, disaster was
not limited to the horrors that they saw on the
silver screen. Approximately five minutes into
the film, a college student named Phil Stevens
stepped into the bathroom, where he was stabbed
in the face and killed by a new Ghostface killer.
Like Sidney and Billy, he too was connected
to Sunrise Studios. Phil Stevens is the son of
the studio’s commissary chef, Martin Stevens. So
again, I have to ask: could this be a coincidence?
Like my answer about Maureen and Henry, I think
his connection to the studio is only tangential.
The killers this time around were Windsor College
student Mickey Altieri and Billy Loomis’s mother,
Debbie. Debbie wasn’t married to Henry
Loomis at the time he worked at Sunrise,
so I don’t think she’d have any way of knowing
who was and was not related to a Sunrise employee.
It would also later be discovered that the
victims were chosen specifically, not because
of any Hollywood blood connection, but rather
because the killers were trying to recreate the
killings in Woodsboro by using people with
similar names. So in the end, I think that
Phil was probably at the screening because
he got the free tickets from his dad. Maybe
his interest in horror movies even spawned from
having a family member work at the movie studio.
But it’s unlikely that that family connection has
anything to do with why he was chosen as a victim.
The killer at the theater,
which was most likely Mickey,
since he goes to college with the
victims and has been known to carryaround
a camcorder, steals Phil’s jacket
and returns to his seat in the auditorium,
where he then stabs Phil’s girlfriend Maureen, who
dies very publicly in front of the movie audience.
This incident gets a ton of coverage in the press,
and the studio discusses the possibility
of even pulling the movie, although,
this was most likely just virtue signaling; in
reality they likely had no intention of doing so.
– It’d be stupid to pull this movie. With all
this free press they’re gonna
have huge numbers this weekend.
– The incident fueled a cultural discussion about
if the movie could have been responsible for
the crimes that occured in the theater. So in
actuality, they promote the movie even harder,
sending the star, Tori Spelling on
television to be interviewed by Nancy O’Dell.
– So tell us about this part
you’re getting rave reviews for.
– Well I play this young girl, Sidney
Prescott, who discovers that her
boyfriend’s this crazy serial killer, who
also killed her mother the year before that.
– So what kind of research
did you do for the part?
– But during this theatrical run, the events
of the next Stab film were playing out in
real life at Windsor College, where the
real Sidney Prescott was taking classes.
Once again, Gale Weathers showed
up to report on the new story.
Sorority girl Cici Cooper was stabbed
and thrown over her balcony. Sidney
herself is attacked that same night,
but manages to survive. The next day,
Randy is not so lucky. Mickey manages to take
out Sidney’s two security details, her roommate,
and her boyfriend before Sidney and Cotton
manage to get the better of him and Mrs. Loomis.
While Mrs. Loomis had only been out for revenge,
Mickey’s motive is significant to the Stab
franchise. He actually wanted to get caught.
– [Mickey] I’ve got my whole defense planned
out. I’m gonna blame the movies.
– For him, it was all about the trial and the
entertainment and attention that comes with it.
It’s likely that he was jealous of all the
extra notoriety that former NFL player OJ
Simpson gained during his murder trial, which
occured a couple years beforehard in 1995.
According to Forbes, “More than 150 million
viewers, 57% of the country, tuned in to
watch the live broadcast of the verdict at
10 a.m. on Oct. 3, 1995.” For comparison,
that’s more than that year’s Super Bowl, which
drew in 125 million. News stations covered OJ
continuously throughout the year, so Mickey
probably envisioned himself in that spotlight.
Those plans were foiled when he and
Mrs. Loomis were killed that evening,
so he never got his big trial, but he would
still receive a lot posthumous media attention
as the villain in Gale Weathers’s new
book: The Windsor College Murders.
Per Gale’s website: “Ms. Weathers is once
again in the eye of a dangerous storm and
emerges a hero. This time, murder
follows Sidney Prescott to college,
where Ms. Weathers is covering a story on
the copycat murders of two students during
a screening of the hit slasher film.
Read how Gale single handedly brought
the killers to justice in this exciting
novel that became the hit movie Stab 2.”
That description might be slightly
embellished, considering she was
actually passed out in an orchestra pit
when the killers were brought to justice,
but I’m sure Sidney wouldn’t mind having
the spotlight shifted away from her.
It was probably around this time when John
Milton greenlighted the production of Stab 2,
but before that would happen, there was still
the home-video release of Stab 1 to worry about.
Stab is listed as having a 111
minute runtime, same as Scream,
though it’s not known if that refers to
the theatrical cut or the home media cut.
I’m not calling it the extended cut, because just
based on the opening scene where Casey is killed,
it seems that the theatrical
cut is nearly 4 minutes longer.
The biggest difference is
probably the music. In the
theatrical cut we hear the song Red Right Hand…
🎵"Red Right Hand" - Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds 🎵
…whereas the home-release cut
contains these haunting strings.
(spooky music)
The out-of-universe explanation for this is
that Scre4m is the only film not to contain
the song "Red Right Hand" at all. According to
scream.fandom.com this is because of a copyright
issue, though they don’t link any evidence to
back that up. I’m guessing they’re trying to say
Scream 4 couldn’t afford the licensing fee. The
fourth movie has the same budget as the third,
but if you adjust both for inflation,
the fourth is actually 30% lower.
This could also serve as an in-universe
explanation. Maybe the studio had the budget
for "Red Right Hand" for the theatrical rights only.
And this really happens from time to time. To use
another example from 1997, the MTV show Daria
first aired with music from popular artists,
but it had to be replaced with stock
music for the VHS and DVD releases.
I’ve lined both cuts of Stab
up by all their common points,
and I’m going to do a full comparison of
the two. The theatrical cut from Scream
2 is on the left and the home media cut
from Scre4m is on the right. But first,
there’s one thing I want to highlight
that neither of these shows: the previews.
Because nobody wants to be advertised to while
they’re in the middle of watching something.
(impact)
(horror drone)
OK, so whenever one of the cuts has
added content, I’ll just pause the
opposite version. And if you don’t care about
the miniscule differences between the cuts,
feel free to just skip to the next chapter
of this video. The fourth Scream shows this
Robert Rodriguez title card, which we don’t
see in Scream 2, but it probably did happen
before Phil and Maureen walked into
the theater. Then we’re in sync…
(knives slashing and music)
(crowd cheers)
…until this part, there’s an added scene in the
home release, but we don’t see it. We’ll fast
forward through the parts where neither Stab
is shown until the Gale Weathers title card.
Then we’ve got more of neither Stab being shown,
but there are some nice parallels. Then there
is a section where there’s added content on the
Blu-Ray, but again, we don’t see it until here,
and it’s just a black screen. Very exciting. But
it leads into the fade-in to the Becker house.
There are four extra seconds in the theatrical
cut which we don’t see… followed by five extra
seconds of Casey entering the bathroom and
turning on the light. We’re back in sync.
(crowd jeering)
– [Gale] Ooh yeah. Back on my game.
– [Zac] Then there’s a long added portion in the
home-release cut, a minute and 38, but we
don’t see any of it because Scream 4 is focused
on Gale, before finally Casey turns on the shower.
And you’ll notice some of these bathroom shots
that linger a little bit are
cut down for the home release.
(spooky music, cheering crowd)
Audiences are just as excited about seeing
Heather Graham’s back in 2010 as they were
back in 1997. Then we don’t see either Stab so
we can fast forward here, where we still
don’t see either screen yet, but there are 4-5
seconds cut of the home release. We actually
see slightly more of the shot of Casey turning
around in Scream 4, which makes me wonder if the
full cut is sitting around somewhere. I’ll do a
short fast forward to Casey walking to the phone.
(phone ringing)
Then there’s a second added to home release, to
put us back in sync for Casey answering the phone.
– Hello?
– [caller] Hello.
– Who is this?
– [Zac] There are big chunks of the conversation
only present in the theatrical cut. I
wonder if this is considered lost
media in the Scream universe.
– [caller] Were you expecting somebody?
– Home release must be the definitive
version, because everybody has it memorized.
– No.
– [Zac] And then the whole section of Casey walking around
the house and talking to Ghostface was actually
cut out of the home release as well. Which is
a shame because we miss this hilarious line.
– [Casey] I don't even have a boyfriend right now.
– [caller] Would you liiikeeee oneee??? Hmm?
– [Zac] This section is another portion that was removed
from the home release. On the Scream 2 side,
we don’t see Stab, but we do hear Ghostface
taunting her. Nothing’s really happening,
I can kind of see why they cut
this, so I’ll fast forward again to…
– You know I don't even know you, and I dislike you already!
– [Zac] Then it’s back to seeing neither Stab,
so I will fly through this and note that
this includes another huge chunk of the
theatrical cut that was removed from the
home release. The cut portion is one minute
and 42 seconds and we don’t see any of it.
(glass shatters)
(screams)
Then, these 5 seconds are only
present in the home release.
The next part may or may not
be in sync, we don’t know,
because we only see a tiny glimpse of the
screen in Scream 2, so I'm fast forwarding.
This is probably in both cuts, we
only see it in Scream 2 though,
so I just figured I’d show you this in
real time, because we’re about to...
Fast forward! To a shot you can
only see in the home release.
We skip forward again landing us in another big
portion that was removed before the home release,
this one lasts 2 minutes and 23 seconds
overall, part of which includes this shot:
(intense music)
And… this shot.
And these three shots…
(suspenseful music)
And who could forget these?
(dramatic music and screaming crowd)
(fast forward)
(flesh stab)
(blood curdling scream)
(moan)
It’s likely that some of these shots
were condensed and included somewhere
in the home release, during
one of the off-screen portions
because they’re kind of important
to get us from point A to point B.
Then this next part is weird, we
actually cut back to Stab in both movies,
first in Scream 4, then moments later in Scream 2,
So I had to pause Scream 4 because
they’re showing different shots entirely.
Obviously things don’t match
up between the two because of
the different shot being used. But
then we fast forward again up until…
Another big chunk that is only in the theatrical
cut. This one lasts 22 seconds and includes both
of these shots. Then there’s one last
point where the two movies are in sync…
And that is the last part we
see of Stab in Scre4m. There’s
a little bit more Stab footage shown
in Scream 2 before the scene ends.
Well that was fun. Unless you skipped
it, in which case: moving right along.
With the release of Gale Weathers’s new book in
1997, the race was on to make a sequel to Stab.
The producers of Stab would return, and
be joined by Floyd Malone and Fred Rifkin,
who had worked with Milton before on Is
Somebody There? and 1st House on the Right.
This time, Jerry Rapp got the call
to direct. I’m not sure if this is
the same Jerry Rapp that went on
to write the movie: Looking Glass.
Everyone else returned for Stab 2, but the
new character additions were decidedly less
star studded than the original film with Dusty
Penn as Sidney’s new boyfriend Derek Feldman,
Sharon Batton as the sorority girl Cici
Cooper, KC Storm as the movie obsessed
killer Mickey Altieri, and Lauren Velez
as Sidney’s roommate Hallie McDaniel.
Notably, there were two additional characters
added who weren’t a part of the real events:
Sonia and Alli. I’m guessing they were
brought on to be additional victims,
to add some extra gore to the movie.
Although the movie was produced and finished
very quickly, it was not without struggle,
thanks to the high tensions between producers
John Milton and Fred Rifkin on set. According to
the Sunrise Sucks website, “the duo had a number
of run-ins over the years, but none matched the
one on (the) set of Stab 2, where there was a
huge blow-out on location at Columbia College,
a school known for producing the
iconic horror YouTuber: CZsWorld.
Milton allegedly was going through drug addiction
issues at the time, and Rifken wanted him banned
from the set, but Tori Spelling used her
influence to protect Milton. As a result,
the production was split into two camps,
and things eventually boiled into a physical
confrontation between Rifkin and Milton. The
two had to be pulled apart, and this time,
Milton was banned from being on set, which made
Spelling and other cast members very unhappy.
Despite the drama, after much anticipation,
the Stab 2 trailer was released.
– [female voice] Last night, two students were brutally murdered,
at a local movie theater.
(impact sound)
(foreboding music)
The first trailer for Stab 2 features a lot
of familiar scenes, yet, unfamiliar faces.
– This is Gale Weathers reporting live.
– [Zac] No. No it is not. This trailer was a bonus feature
on the DVD for Scream 3. The obvious answer as to
why the cast is filled with random people is
that like the other bonus stuff from Scream 3,
it’s not canon. But again, I’m gonna
come up with an excuse to incorporate
it because it’s the closest thing
we have to footage from Stab 2.
Until a Scream movie gives us actual footage
of Stab 2, this is too much fun to leave out.
So think about it like this. In Scream
2, the movie within the movie is Stab.
But if Stab 2 is the in-universe equivalent
of Scream 2, then there has to be another
movie within the movie in Stab 2. The movie
that the Stab versions of Maureen Evans and
Phil Stevens go to see at the beginning.
I think that’s what we’re seeing here.
Just as this clip was originally used to
promote Scream 3 in our real life universe,
it would also have been used in the Scream
universe to promote Stab 2. There is actually
some precedent for the Stab movies inside the
Stab franchise still just being called Stab.
Remember that the opening of Stab 7 is two girls
sitting on a couch watching a movie called Stab 6.
One interesting thing about the Stab 2
trailer is that it seems to stray further
from the actual events of Scream 2 than the
original Stab did. For one, Windsor College is
now “Columbia University.” There are also brand
new Ghostface scenes, seemingly new characters,
I’m guessing this is Alli, played by Angela
Kong, and even some creative liberties in
the dialogue. For example, in Scream 2,
we never hear the end of the third rule.
– [Randy] And number three, if you want your
sequel to become a franchise, never ever--
– How do we find the killer
Randy? That’s what I want to know.
– But in the Stab 2 trailer,
we hear all of them in full.
– Number one, body count’s always higher.
Number two, the death scenes are much more
elaborate. Number three, never ever under any
circumstances assume that the killer is dead.
– The hype must have been high for Stab 2, because
it seems that before the movie was even released,
the studio greenlit another sequel. Stab 2 was
most likely released in the summer of 1999,
based on the fact that while Stab
3 was shooting in August 1999,
they are actively advertising
Stab 2 on buses in LA.
The movie begins with two new murders at a
movie sneak preview of Stab. It’s discovered
both are students at Sidney Prescott and Randy
Meeks’s college. Naturally, Gale Weathers shows
up to cover the story, but this time has to go up
against another reporter who goes by Deborah Salt.
Gale attempts to set up a reconciliation interview
between Sidney and Cotton, but Sidney is not
interested. Dewey also flies into town to try to
help protect Sid when he hears what’s going on.
That night, a sorority girl named
Cici gets taken out by Ghostface,
and Sidney narrowly avoids the knife herself. Her
boyfriend, Derek, helps fight off the intruder,
but since nobody actually saw his fight with
Ghostface, he becomes a suspect, due to the injury
on his arm conveniently missing any critical
arteries, and he is a medical student after all.
Sidney’s roommate, Hallie, and her film nerd
friend Mickey also get interrogated and Sidney
is given a personal security detail. The
next day, Derek tries to calm Sidney’s
worries by serenading her in front of the whole
dining hall and giving her his Greek letters,
but a Ghostface encounter during a rehearsal for
a play that she’s in still leaves her shaken.
Dewey, Gale and Randy determine that the culprit
is trying to recreate what happened in Woodsboro,
but this time using the rules and tropes that
dictate horror movie sequels. They receive a
mysterious call, but while trying to track down
the caller, Randy is abducted and loses his life.
Meanwhile, Sidney has a scary confrontation with
Cotton Weary, who still wants his interview,
and he’s arrested, if only temporarily,
as they have no evidence against him.
Not long after, Dewey and Gale are attacked
while reviewing film evidence and Sidney and
Hallie are attacked while fleeing town in
a vehicle with Sidney’s security guards.
Sidney ends up being the only one to
get away from the car crash alive and
soon after finds herself lured into a trap on
the stage of the play she was set to star in.
After sacrificing Sidney’s
boyfriend in front of her,
the killers reveal themselves as Mickey
and Deborah Salt, or as Sidney knows her,
Mrs. Loomis, Billy’s vengeful mother. With a
little help from Gale and eventually Cotton,
she’s able to defeat her attackers once again
and Dewey even lives to see another day.
As I mentioned, production on Stab 3: Return to
Woodsboro had already begun at some point during
the second movie’s theatrical run. Location
scouting began in June 1999, and casting was
completed before the end of the first week of
June. This time, much of the original cast did
not come back, including Tori Spelling, David
Schwimmer and Craig Bierko. Some have speculated
that they did not feel comfortable starring in
a franchise that was connected to so much real
crime, but I would guess that maybe they weren’t
interested in doing a fictional continuation
of a nonfiction story. Kind of like how Kate
Winslet wasn’t in Titanic II. It’s also likely
that Tori Spelling did not want to return thanks
to infighting and tension on set during Stab 2.
The studio held a massive talent search to find
the next Sidney Prescott, in which 50,000 girls
tried out. The part ended up going to newcomer
Angelina Tyler, which she was able to secure
by sleeping with the producer, John Milton. The
new Deputy Dewey Riley would be actor Tom Prinze,
who was well enough to play the part
despite crashing his car a month prior.
To fill Craig Bierko’s role as Cotton Weary,
they simply got the real Cotton Weary to
make a small cameo as himself. Jennifer
Jolie reprised her role as Gale Weathers.
Since many fans were upset about the
decision to kill off Randy in Stab 2,
a new character named Ricky, another video
store employee, was created as an homage
and the role was given to Tyson Fox. Fox is
rumored to be the illegitimate son of Sunrise
Studios head Don Crosby and actress Leticia
Yanci. Similarly, the new character, Candy,
seems to be an homage to Tatum, from Stab 1,
and this spot would be filled by 35-year-old
Sarah Darling, at the request of her agent…
even though she wasn’t thrilled about it.
– Stab 3. Jesus I gotta get a new agent.
– Supporting cast included Dan
Arrdondo as the Swimming Coach,
Barry Barclay as Computer Geek #1 and Brett
Riley as Obsessive Fan. It seems the movie
also included multiple Ghostface killers, a
sheriff, a principal, an innocent crash victim,
a hooker, an english teacher, a woman named
Jan and a man named Ted, among others.
As for the production team, Fred Rifkin was
initially supposed to direct, but according to the
documents in Sunrise Sucks, he was already not in
good standing with other producers after repeated
conflicts while shooting Stab 2. However, he
wasn’t removed until after one scandalous evening,
where John Milton shared a $25,000 hotel room with
Hollywood agent Beverly Choi. Choi represents the
acclaimed music video director Roman Bridger,
who happens to be Maureen Prescott’s bastard son.
Just two days after Choi and Milton slept
together, Rifkin was fired from Stab 3 and
Roman was brought on to replace him as part
of a two movie deal with Sunrise Studios.
Strangely, in this interview with Gale
Weathers, Roman claims that he cannot reveal
anything about Stab 3, including basic
information about who’s starring in it,
due to a sworn secrecy with Milton, who he
refers to as “Master Milton.” Apparently,
this confidentiality is so secretive that he can’t
even communicate with Jerry Rapp, the director of
Stab 2, about it. This extreme dedication to
secrecy extended to Will Kennison’s script.
– The producers told us that there were
three different versions of the script,
something about trying to keep
the ending off the internet.
– Another challenge arose when longtime Director
of Photography Hawken Jones passed away
not long before shooting, and
was replaced by Peter Deming,
who shot Evil Dead 2 and Austin
Powers: International Man of Mystery.
The only other notable crew brought on
was Dewey Riley himself, who was hired as
a technical advisor due to his experience
in surviving both Woodsboro and Windsor.
Jennifer Jolie credited Dewey with helping
her understand the real Gale Weathers,
but it’s likely that Dewey only took the position
as a crutch after his break up with the real Gale.
If he couldn’t have the woman he wanted, being
around her best imitator was the next best thing.
In addition to all that,
John Milton allegedly still owed Gale
money for the right to adapt her books.
Despite all the tension and drama
during the pre-production stages,
Stab 3’s production would make those
problems look like a walk in the park,
as things were about to get
a whole lot more serious.
(impact)
(dark music)
Distribution and production meetings
for Stab 3: Return to Woodsboro were
held near the end of June, with principal
photography most likely beginning in July,
with plans to continue shooting
through August and into September,
wrapping with second unit shoots
in the latter half of the month.
Though we don’t know much about
the story, due to its fictional
nature and the fact that it was never
completed, we can pick up little details.
August 2 and August 3 are shot in a
location called “Dorm Bathroom” and
the first kill of the movie involves the
Candy getting killed while in the shower.
Other shoot locations include Sid’s
Dorm Room, the Library , a Coffee House,
and Sid’s party. This would suggest that Sidney
is still in college in this movie. The others
are fairly generic locations: houses, a
hospital, and somewhere called Grant Hill.
Obviously the subtitle of the
film is “Return to Woodsboro”,
so a big part of it must be the main location:
Woodsboro. We see huge sets being constructed,
including Sidney’s house, Stu
Macher’s house, the TV news van,
Sidney’s childhood room, and even Stu’s
garage, which judging by the open fridge
and prop blood on the pet flap, looks
to be a part of a series of flashbacks.
Based on this, I’m going to infer that Stab
3: Return to Woodsboro was about a new pair of
Ghostface killers who start attacking more people
at Sidney’s college, prompting administrators
to cancel classes and send students home --
essentially the college version of what happened
in Stab 1 and Scream 1. Returning home causes
Sidney to have a flashback to her mother’s murder.
– [Tom] Scene 34. Maureen’s murder flashback.
– [Zac] Once she’s back in Woodsboro, the killers
try to recreate each of the scenes from the
original Stab, with the new addition of
Ricky, who gets a huge pair of scissors
through the head. But this time, the
killers hope to avenge Billy and Stu
by defeating Sidney at the end of the movie.
As Sidney revisits the locations of her past,
she’s also forced to relive flashbacks to
the horrors that she experienced around town.
– [Tom] Scene 40 though 47. The
Prescott house flashback.
– [Zac] But of course she’s not alone, she has new
and old friends that are looking out for her.
– [Tom] Scene 50. Dewey saves the day.
– This is all kind of ironic though, because
Roman is the director of Return to Woodsboro
and in real life, he is also recreating many
of the kills, using the cast of his movie
as his victims. He’s also probably recruited
Angelina Tyler, aka: the new Sidney actress,
to assist him as the second killer. If you want to
know more about that, watch my Scream 3 Things You
Missed, where I talk about the fan theory that
Angelina is the second killer in that movie.
Shooting has begun, and it’s late July
or early August, based on the fact that
Candy is preparing to shoot her death scene,
which is going to roll on August 2 and 3,
when Roman takes his first victim:
Cotton Weary. When the news breaks,
the producers and studio executives get
together to discuss possibly pulling the
plug on the movie, but of course, since
there’s money to be made, they don’t.
– Detectives! There’s no reason to presume
that Cotton’s death had anything to do with
this movie, is there?
– He was making a movie
called Stab. He was stabbed.
– Candy is the next target. Roman calls
her into an after hours meeting in
the production office and one of the
killers corners her in the prop room.
The entire staff is interrogated by
police, and the movie is shut down.
But that doesn’t stop the body count from
rising. First, Jennifer Jolie’s bodyguard
Steven Stone gets the knife. The rest of the cast
receives faxes with new script pages. So Roman is
essentially rewriting his movie in real time, and
the next scene involves Tom Prinze accidentally
using a lighter in Jennifer’s gas-filled
house, causing it to explode with him inside.
Roman also tracks down Sidney, who is living
a secret life of seclusion up to that point,
so she travels to LA to be with Dewey and Gale
so that she doesn’t feel alone. Roman almost seems
to be recreating the events of the Stab
3: Return to Woodsboro script, only instead of
Sidney returning to the real Woodsboro, she’s
returning to the Woodsboro set in Hollywood.
The gang also receives a tape from Randy Meeks,
who explains that they are once again dealing
with a new set of rules; this time they are
in the midst of a trilogy final chapter.
While exploring the movie set
version of her old neighborhood,
Sidney is nearly killed by the Ghostface duo, so
she’s taken to the police station for protection.
While this is going on, Gale, Jennifer
and Dewey show up in John Milton’s office
to confront him about their discovery that
Maureen Prescott was in his movies in the 70s.
Afterwards, they receive a call from a voice
who they believe to be Sidney telling them
she’ll be going to Roman’s birthday party
at John Milton’s mansion, so they decide
to meet her there. Unfortunately for them,
it’s a trap. They discover a voice changer,
cell phone, and Ghostface costume in a
closet, and Gale comes across Roman’s body,
and incorrectly believes that he’s dead,
making it easier for him to take out his
partner Angelina, and then Tyson and
Jennifer without drawing suspicion.
Using Dewey and Gale as hostages, he calls Sidney
over to the party, for real this time. He reveals
himself in the secret screening room, and explains
his entire motive, his desire to get revenge on
the family that shunned him away. He brings
out the hostage that he’s planning to frame:
John Milton, who Roman sees as the source
of his issues, because he allowed Maureen
to be taken advantage of by Hollywood predators,
causing him to be born in shame, and abandoned.
Sidney catches him off guard, and with Dewey’s
help, she’s able to eventually finish him off.
Sidney returns home with her friends,
no longer having to worry about her
past coming forward to haunt her, and
Dewey proposes to Gale -- she accepts.
If all of that sounds like the plot of a
movie, Sunrise Studios agrees with you,
because in place of Stab 3: Return to Woodsboro,
they decided to go forward with a new movie:
Stab 3: Hollywood Horror, based on the failed
production of Stab 3: Return to Woodsboro.
As usual, first came the book, Hollywood Horror
by Gale Weathers. We don’t know exactly when the
movie came out, but there’s a good chance they
waited a little while. For one, they needed to
wait for Gale’s book to come out and reveal the
ending. They also needed to find a new producer
and an entirely new cast, unless of course Tori
Spelling was willing to come back now that it was
based on a true story again. Perhaps she would do
the movie in honor of her good friend John Milton?
It also makes sense that they’d take
a break before doing the next movie.
Not that they’ve ever cared about capitalizing
too soon on a tragedy, but they’d probably
want to take a step back and up their
security before beginning another project.
Regardless of when it came out, it seems like
there is a significant time gap in the narrative.
– How long have you and Dewey been married?
– Ten years.
– Aww, just like your characters in Stab 3. Wow!
– I’m not sure if they were married at the end
of Stab 2, or if this is just something that
happened in between movies, but it seems
to suggest that Stab 3: Hollywood Horror
is set in 2007 or later. However, it must have
come out before that and been set in the near
future -- assuming they aren’t releasing
more than one Stab per year, that is.
We can assume that it did pretty well
at the box office, because the franchise
would soon be brought back with another
attempt at a fictional revival. However,
the real Sidney Prescott did
not like her story being used,
and it’s easy to see why considering all
the trouble the movies have caused her.
– [Jenny] But then she threatened to
sue them if they used her story,
so then they just started making stuff up.
–  [Zac] So the Sidney character that they had
created continued to be in the movies,
but they were no longer related to any
events relating to her real life.
Gale Weathers also wanted to continue cashing in
on the Ghostface IP with a fictional
installment, so she wrote this book,
Ghostface Returns, though it’s not clear if
this was before or after the release of Stab
4. I’d assume one of the post-trilogy films
was probably based off of this book though.
Next up was Stab 5: Clock of Doom, which
introduced time travel into the fray,
which did not go over well with fans.
– [Richie] This franchise goes off
the rails with number five.
– [Jenny] Stab 5 has time travel,
which is by far the worst.
–  Still, the movie did well enough to justify a
sixth film. Stab 6 brings the franchise into
the era of social media by introducing a duo of
Facebook killers. Not much is known about the
actual movie, Stab 6, that exists in the Scream
universe. Remember, I’m going off the assumption
that the Stab movies contain a fictional franchise
of movies-within-the-movie, also called Stab.
Going off the logic established in Scream 2,
where the actors in Stab are different people
than the actors in Scream 1, we can assume that
the footage on your screen right now is not an
actual clip of Stab 6, but rather, the movie
within the movie in Stab 7. But like Stab 1,
it’s probably very close to the real thing with
only a few minor differences, so let’s explore
the opening of Stab 6, which contains one detail
that tells us more than you might have realized.
(impact)
(phone ringing)
– [Sherry] Hello?
– [caller] Hello.
– [Sherry] Uhh yes?
– [caller] Who is this?
– Stab 6 opens up with an homage to the
original Stab, a teenage girl answering
a phone call from a mysterious caller.
Our characters are Sherry and Trudy,
and like Casey from that original movie, they
are getting ready to watch a horror movie.
Sherry picks Saw IV, and although Trudy isn’t
a fan, this helps us place the movie in the
Stab timeline, because Saw IV was released on
DVD and Blu-ray in January 2008, meaning that
this movie takes place some time after that.
We already established that Stab 4 takes place,
at the very earliest, in 2007, and Stab 5 has
time travel, making it impossible to place,
so ‘08 seems reasonable here, especially
given that it involves a Facebook killer,
Trudy is using a Sidekick phone and
Sherry still has standard definition TV.
The two discuss Trudy’s Facebook
stalker when the phone rings with
a threatening voice on the other line.
– YOU HANG UP ON ME AND I’LL CUT
THROUGH YOUR NECK UNTIL I FEEL BONE!
– [Zac] Trudy suddenly becomes worried, and checks
to make sure the doors are locked when the
doorbell rings and a message comes in
daring them to open it. Sherry does so,
to reveal seemingly no one, but another text
gives them a better idea of the killer’s location.
– It says, ‘I’m not outside. I’m right
beside you.’
(screams)
– [Zac] And when Sherry tries to run,
she’s cut off by the second killer,
who makes good on the promise about her neck.
And that is basically, all I can tell you about
Stab 6, if indeed that actually happens in Stab 6,
because the clips you just saw are
from Stab 7. So let’s move onto Stab 7.
For the first time in a while, I can definitively
tell you a little bit about the cast. Stab 6
Sherry was played by Lucy Hale. We can’t say for
sure what she might have been known for at the
time, because we don’t know exactly when Stab 7,
or any of the other post-trilogy Stabs came out.
My best guess is that it came out in 2008, because
in Scream 4, Charlie says that Stab-a-thon is
a marathon of all 7 Stab movies and that this
is their 3rd annual Stab-a-thon. However, I’m
not gonna nail that down, because it’s entirely
possible that in previous years, Stab-a-thon was
only a 6 movie marathon. So it’s impossible
to say when movies 4-7 came out for sure.
We can’t even really use that Saw 4
reference in Stab 6 to help nail down
a date, because the later Stab films
all take place in the near future,
so the existence of a fourth Saw movie
could have very well just been a prediction.
Anyway, Lucy Hale is joined by Shenae Grimes as
her friend, Trudie. The actual Stab 7 characters
are Chloe and Rachel. Chloe is played by Kristen
Bell, and Rachel is played by Anna Paquin,
who was a child star who started acting at four
years old and played Rogue in the 2000 X-men.
After watching the intro of Stab 6, Rachel
turns off the movie, and complains that the
whole self-aware post-modern meta horror
has been done to death. Chloe argues that
she likes the realism of the Stab… which is
ironic considering Stab 5 had time travel,
but Rachel counters by ragging on the formulaic
nature of a franchise with too many sequels.
– [Rachel] There’s no element of
surprise, you can see everything
coming.
(scream)
– [Zac] Chloe tells her to shut up and watch the
movie, and with one more stab, she turns
the movie back on and continues watching. It
seems that Stab 7 shares the goals of Scream 4
in that it’s all about doing the unexpected. Not
only is the timing of Chloe’s attack surprising,
but the intro also leaves us with a surviving
killer who we know the identity of for the first
time. In this sense, Stab 7 directly addresses the
fans’ criticism about the movies’ predictability.
Unfortunately for Stab fans, the series seems
to have a hiatus after this, another example
of it running parallel to the Scream franchise.
At some point, Sunrise released a Stab box set,
which included a documentary about the true story
behind the Stab trilogy. The box set contains
Stabs 1-7 on Blu-ray. The films would also make
their way onto the streaming website Netflix.
After over a decade of waiting, fans would
be subjected to a new self-titled movie:
Stab (2021). It seems the new iteration was
directed or produced by Rian Johnson, who had made
quite a name for himself over the previous
decade with Looper, The Last Jedi and Knives Out.
To promote the movie, Johnson
did an interview on Dead Meat.
The film clocked in at a whopping 2 hours
and 32 minutes and was given an R rating.
Stab (2021) appears to be another fictional
endeavor, despite the fact that the real
Sidney did survive a a new set of killers in
2010 in Woodsboro, where she was attacked by
her cousin and her boyfriend. It’s likely
that Sunrise Studios did not try to use
this story because of Sidney’s threats of a
lawsuit if they used her real story. In fact,
this would be the first Stab film not to
feature a Sidney Prescott character at all.
– [caller] Sidney’s in every movie but the last one.
– But even though this eighth
installment would mostly be fictional,
there are little connections to
the second Woodsboro murders,
like the inclusion of a character
to represent Deputy Judy Hicks.
– Jesus, my mom was a character in one of them…
– …and the title, simply being: Stab, which
suggests this movie is probably a requel.
The killers in the second Woodsboro murders
(aka: Scream 4) were out to create a requel.
Only one casting choice is known. Matthew
Lillard was the voice of the new
villain: Flamethrower Ghostface.
Despite the copious amounts of hype for this
movie, fans seemed to really dislike it.
– [man computer] And don’t even get me started on
Ghostface’s signature new weapon.
– [Ghostface] That sh*t is lit.
– [woman on computer] And can we talk about the title,
Stab? What, just like the original? Just call it Stab 8. It’s f*cking Stab 8,
you’re not fooling anyone.
– [Zac] Between Ghostface’s new silver face, the
replacement of his robe with a sleeveless hoodie,
the use of a flamethrower, which is a weapon
that does not even Stab it’s victims, the fact
that the killer is so clearly male, eliminating
probably 50% of the suspects and thus making the
movie far more predictable, the lack of legacy
characters and franchise connections, and the
departure from numeric naming conventions, people
were already calling for the studio to redo it,
using the hashtags #RedoStab8 and
#RedoStab2021 to drum up a movement.
– You go on 4chan and Dreadit, all they’re talking
about is how Stab 8 pissed on their childhoods.
How they crammed in social commentary just to make
it elevated. How the main character’s a Mary Sue.
– What’s a Mary Sue?
– You really don’t want to know.
– The film was so bad, it even
drove a crazed superfan to
engage in a new set of Woodsboro murders.
– Anyway, it sucked balls. Because nobody
takes the true fans seriously. Not really.
– However, after defeating Ghostface number 9
and 10, Sidney and Gale decide not to ever
speak publicly about the incident
so that the evil doers would die in
anonymity. Does this spell the end for the
Stab franchise? It will certainly be harder
for the movies to remain relevant
without a real life connection,
and without Gale to even write any fictional
stories upon which to base the movies.
But if Stab and the movie industry has taught
us anything, it’s that as long as there’s
a dime to be made off of the Stab IP, you can
probably expect more garbage to be shoveled out.
At least we know Rian Johnson is getting work.
(impact)
I want to give a thanks to Joey Noberini II.
He archived all of those old Scream websites that are no longer online,
so this video would not have been fully possible if not for his contribution.
If you want to learn more about the history of the
Scream franchise, head on over to that playlist on
the left, where I’ll be analyzing many characters
in the Scream canon. If you love horror,
make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell and
select all notifications and I’ll see you
in the next one. Assuming, we both survive.
(spooky dance music)